ippon il ferait cavalier f3 cavaliers m6
karine fournier première licence à 8 ans
second championnat de france à 14 ans il
est repéré par victor hagen qui décident
de l'entraîner grand favori du tournoi
aucune faille de ses adversaires lui
échappe j'ai gagné comme toi tu as bien
joué
enfin quand europe le champion de france
du siècle arrive pas à me faire jouer
walo
jonas and the lady gaga venir des
joueurs d'échecs fait nous gagnons nos
parties du jour [ __ ] de l'esav partout
vient voir technics ira très molle c'est
peut être comme éminemment max kovac
m
mais mieux d'espagne oeuvre d'art est un
gain 80 l'obsession joue comme je te dis
être le dernier
il transforme
experts sont ni tandis qu'il est fini
je me l'appliqué